[Music]  congratulations on your Golden Globe  nomination this is so exciting  where were you when you heard I was up  because my boyfriend was getting ready  to take a flight this morning and my  phone just happened to light up and it  was my love like congratulations it  couldn't be more fitting to hear such an  incredible crazy bananas news from my  level I love that my love is the first  to call you we're very tight we thought  you again nomination - to be honest I  agree I agree I mean I'm very  appreciative but but I agree I think  everyone I think everyone in this cast  deserve to be not hated I am so honored  but I am most excited about the show  getting nominated I mean I think there's  no way that I would be here and be  acknowledged without the work of  everyone